[Musique]
les cas ça me sens déjà de la vie si
tous kankan et passes-tu cieux belle
cette expulsion le plus sérieux ça me
faisait pas jouer il suffit de vouloir
devenir amis
[Musique]
m
en projet ce pas déjà pas le coeur à
chanter pourquoi je me suis fait traiter
de vieux corbeau non oui mais où sa
balade dans les bois c'est pas ça fait
pas plaisir
le pi qui passait au désagréable alors
jouons pour oublier aller à quoi bas ou
jeu de l'ès graphique est le point
commun on pensera tout à l'heure je
crois certainement alors le alors là le
contour le contour du pays
c'est que j'appelle ça comme ça tu
appelles ça comme ça le contour du pays
d'abord c'est le premier élément alors
le comptoir je rappelle si tu le veux
bien
il faut découvrir le nom d'un pays à
partir de trois éléments c'est ça alger
dabou et tu as tu pas que nos petites
secondes d'abord leur autour du pays a
même déjà plus c'est déjà plus des
piscines
alors la capitale est ici elle est
marquée oui remarque je crois avoir une
idée enfin c'est déjà plus difficile on
est bridée oui si tu peux alors le grand
bain co le drapeau des drapeaux regardez
bien le drapeau de ce pays
faux c'est donc parce qu'ils n'ont pas
la couleur
oui mais je t'explique et pour ceux qui
n'ont pas la couleur nous avons là le
rouge et nous avons là le blanc nous bon
alors maintenant le troisième élément
pour ceux qui n'ont pas trouvé alors
c'est très bon jour dans la langue du
pays
ça va pas ça va pas être facile c'est un
ca l'y attend ouh là là là là là voilà
comme nietzsche i oi et comme ça se
prononce ici tu veux oui oui oui ça veut
dire bonjour ça va la commission
sayonara wallon jardin sayonara oui eh
ben je vais te dire le nom de ce pays
à mon avis si je ne me trompe pas c'est
le l'europe on voit là a alors et la
capitale du japon qui se trouvent ici
c'est merci aux futurs fly away nous
peter chan a aucun rapport voilà le
drapeau le pays du japon ce sont des
îles vous le voyez et comme ni de
chihuahua le la façon de dire bonjour et
sayonara c'est en voir je pense pas
sayonara sur voie alors saiosn arabe
tout en or à fabrice sayonara vite do
with et ghemara sayonara l'attend pas
alors oui comme monty welcome et tu vois
les gemmois on l'appelle oui difficile à
lui servait bon fabry si oui à quoi je
n'ai pas tapé à chaque fois tu devrais
le savoir qui ferait rentrer de toi même
non mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
d'aller comme ça c'est que de paroles
perdues bon dieu se finit non bon il est
énervé aujourd'hui un fraudeur sourire
bonjour aux mondiaux pas beau xvie
bonhommie ce qui fait de la hausse
moindre équipe à milan d'un abri et baky
c'est sympa qui disait ça a été ma part
que des os et piquant oui qu'est ce que
tu fais là bas se prenaient alors je
suis venue voir l'émission oui bah alors
tu nous laisses nous concentrons
d'accord d'accord c'est le point commun
est la dernière fois je n'ai pas réussi
alors attention comme nietzsche et ouais
mais comme dit shioiri commence alors le
point commun ba rappelons que vous êtes
chacun quelque chose et que je la
trouvais le point commun qui vous unit
voilà waiba loire on me trouve dans les
jardins mais alors attention je ne suis
pas du tout une mauvaise herbe prône
arrache non je ne suis pas non plus une
fleur ni un arbre
un fruit non plus d'ailleurs je suis
rien de tout ça non pour tout dire je
suis quelque chose qui ne pousse pas
mais si j'étais pas de temps en temps il
ya beaucoup de choses qui auraient bien
du mal à pousser aux remarques et je
suis très facile à reconnaître et si
quelqu'un si tu passes dans la cabane
d'un jardinier tu me verras dans un coin
et puis tu me reconnaîtras je m'étale
jamais et al et puis j'ai plein de
petits trous sur la figure tu vois je
vois pour bien ne voit pas mais moi
aussi je suis dans les jardins mais dieu
soit loué
on ne meurt relève pas dans la cabane
des jardiniers je suis exposé à la vue
de tout le monde
à l'hiver bien entendu mais à la belle
saison et j'ai de belles couleurs rouge
vert jaune lui j'ai du goût et du parfum
on me trouve un peu partout en france
mais surtout en normandie et en bretagne
et on a trouvé tellement de moyens de
m'utiliser et que je renonce à les
énumérer
il y en a dicté a du talent on ne peut
pas juger une bise
mon but c'est effrayant rien ne dit pas
si c'est pas compliqué je n'ai les
jambes en compote
je crois que ça va mieux ça va mais je
voudrais entendre la version de tous
vous tuer quoi ton tout soupçon bah moi
moi alors mme hélas moi je vis dans la
terre oh c'est une vie difficile au jeu
toujours dans l'obscurité dans
l'humidité et personne ne vient
m'admirer comme bell bell souvent on
passe au dessus de moi sont sans même
savoir que je suis là vu que j'existe
mais mais mais heureusement il arrive un
moment où on ne fait sortir de mon trou
et là alors je prends ma revanche
parce que je peux le dire je veux le
dire on n'apprécie pas qu'on a une
curieuse façon de m'apprécier on ne
coupe pour m'écrase on ne plonge dans
l'huile bouillante
il y en a qui n'aimeraient pas ça du
tout mais moi moi moi ça m'est égal non
l'idée que tous les jours je fais
plaisir à tant de gens bain
ça suffit à mon bonheur tu vois je suis
comme ça je crois maintenant que j'ai
trouvé et vous est-ce que vous avez
également trouver et en dans la cabane
du jardinier tout cas encore oui
détendez rouge des vertes et des pas
mûres des jours et puis alors dans la
plaie oui eh bien moi je verrais bien
une pomme d'arrosoir le pommeau le fruit
de pommes de terre
bell bell est préparé le jeu musical
justement j'aime exercer déjà habitué à
chanter une autre petite chance soit à
l'heure d'accord bon allez je vous
laisse au revoir belge elle je te
retrouverai tout à l'heure il en tout
cas encore est-ce qu'il ya capture est
avec nous s'il te plaît pas mais je
pense qu'on va nous proposer pouces vous
ce matin bah oui c'est son jeu on va on
va jouer
attention pouces moussu oui ne fait pas
d'erreur oh ça oui c'est je sais c'est à
mes yeux les airs et enfin essayons si
on va essayer d'aller bon alors et à ton
tableau magie suis bon alors je
t'annonce cette fois ci un mohand il est
oui on commence par bah on commence par
un h
oui achoui a jailli la dernière lettre
alors c'est un up
alors andy lettre à temps parce que
c'est difficile ça il ya vingt-huit très
huit petits traits qui représente les
autres lettres un wii 2 3 4 5 6 7 et 8
bravo doit bien alors tout de suite est
ce que c'est une fleur
non c'est pas une fleur est ce que c'est
un fruit non plus c'est pas un fruit
est ce que c'est un arbre c'est pas un
arbre alors c'est un animal et ben voilà
elle va voir l'animal c'est un petit
animal en ont au nom c'est un gros ou
l'autre gros gros animal nourri
you should fort ni ce que c'est un
animal qui
qui va très vite oui bien suivi qui va
célébrer ses rites
il est lourd très lourd il est doux il à
quatre pattes 4,4 et d'ailleurs je suis
pas tellement sûr parce que on ne voit
pas très bien ses pattes à un
renouvellement hillairaud télé gros il
est énorme et scala en france on ou non
non non non et non en europe plus
généralement en afrique en afrique en
dehors les animaux africains
j'adore les films j'adore ça alors que
je te donne de la manette
qu'est ce que tu veux ça avait donné une
lettre alors c'est un p 1 pén aide
supplémentaire le met où le pays bas ont
battu mais à la troisième à la troisième
dette oui voilà mais dis donc je pense
grosse que moi quelque chose oui est ce
que par hasard et pour une fois tu
n'aurais pas fait de fautes
d'orthographe
en effet l'animal auquel je pense qu'on
porte bien ce nombre de lettres
hippopotames hippopotames hip hop on me
paie c'est formidable tu t'es pas leur
anonymat h
y poly9 était trop beau mais non pouces
moussu alanguie ohlala j'avais un espoir
mais pas du tout avant il n'y a pas de y
ces petits bouts au tard est d'accord
vannes oubliez-moi ses hippopotames
mais voilà ça fait rigoler gandhi de
paix la magie de chevet y ait un seul
pays et la main au tam et oui oui tu
t'es trompé dans tout quoi bein je me
suis trompé dans la wii blessés et
pourtant je croyais bien je parle oui
moi aussi j'ai c'est ferrer
ben oui mais malheureusement quelque
chose
j'ai un ami qui m'a dit que hip hop
comme hippodrome
parce qu'il faut c'est un mot qui veut
dire cheval alors est potable
ça veut dire qu'on peut le bréviaire
avec le des rivières alors on a baptisé
cet animal cheval de rivière cvo potable
mais tout ce que je peux dire ça lompo
tam contraire notable bon potable
la belle belle s'il te plaît gg près
allons-y
là tu n'as pas bouffer ce que j'ai fait
cette fois ci la musique guy béart et
que toi nous avons notre portée nous
avons notre clé de sol oui suis en train
de prendre les notes
oui je vais remplacer les mots ou tout
au moins les parties de mots que tu ne
prononcera pas par des notes ici je
regagne qu'ils racontent toutes les
semaines j'étais sûr que tous les
enfants compris depuis longtemps il voir
répéter les choses plutôt que les
oubliés non bâti 6 gdi choses très
importantes à dire mais enfin
commencions ejelat notre petit jeu des
notes de musique alors votre puisque
nous ne sommes pas partis en vacances
je voudrais qu'on organise un pique
nique aux environs de paris on se
trouvera un quoi 2une belfort oui ça
j'aurais pu tout de suite forêt c'est ça
comme le nom d'un grand musicien
il fera de la même façon or qu'il est
bête ces femmes et fois du don fait
attention à ce que tu dis enfin tu sais
bien que je t'aime bon je me dis je
préparerai pour ce pique nique des
groupes annie pour la nourriture
oui car je sais que quand on va déjeuner
en plein air on est toujours à mais ça
ça doit être affamés ah oui ça ido
c'était très dur ça il y aura dès jeudi
dix pâtés et du saucon comment 10 au son
du saulcy sont ci sont alors c'était
pour t'avoir du saucisson et d'étapes
catherine ben oui tartine bugs et qu'est
ce que tu fais là à toi mais puis quand
ben qu'est ce que tu fais à tête qui
tenaient ensemble
nous avons pas pouvoir goûter à ma
spécialité qu'est ce que tu m'as dit la
tarte au rabais aux mirabelles c'est
voilà naturellement il est indispensable
dans un pique nique d'être très bien
installés ce n'est pas parce qu'on est à
la campagne qu'il faut se laisser
envahir par les fours les fourmis les
fourmis les fourmis les formules et le
rhône est à la toutes les provisions sur
une grande toile crack sirènes on dirait
alors ça y est et puis comme je déteste
déjeuner en place à l'est je vous
apporterai un parent à un parent à quoi
ah ça pourrait être un parachute
parasols un parasol
c'est un parasol pis si tu as soif je te
préparer delattre au nahd délabrement
banon celle là quoi la citronnade à de
là-bas alors ça tu me dis de la grogne
monte vite
ronald tulle arias et les oreilles qui
débouche battu ces jeunes c'est à dire
une chose quand on sait se servir des
notes comme ça les a apprises
on peut après faire un petit peu de
musique et qu'est ce que tu en penses de
ce pique nique des quat'zarts des quatre
amis mais alors alors on va on va jouer
quelque chose avec des notes
oui tu veux on va jouer j'ai du bon
tabac si tu veux un
alors tiens tu vas chanter je lui montre
d'ailleurs que tu penses tu vois pas ce
qu'il y'a un truc notamment en matière
j'ai voté
hinano amazon j'aimerais mieux qu'on
achète notre chanson j'arrive
c'est pas mal ma foi la connais
tellement talent ici sur une création
reste au-dessus thèmes et des questions
enfin les quatre sa wii sont déjà
pourquoi pas nous a mis l'état
ça oui le secret de la vie désiste et
j'ai chanté des choses mais comme je n'y
pas de mémoire
il faudra faire attention les gars a mis
son bon parcours des sens réunit les
quatre ça me sens de retard et zari
mais
vous avez à jouer aujourd'hui il voit
revenir à ta vie il suffisait de vouloir
devenir amis
[Musique]